foreign
what if we stopped pretending
foreign
the end of the end of the earth
friends and vive sometimes
christina stalls
some other hate actually
for evie
[Music]
hello
hello
hello thomas
i would like to present thomas levine a
great danish actor and a great reader of
jonathan franson's novels
who are going to read at some point
during this evening
thank you
and hello
hello again
can you tell me
what is the difference between a bird
watcher and a birder
it's a subtle distinction
birders tend to be a little more serious
i think in public
surveys something like 80 million
americans
identify themselves as bird watchers of
some kind
but that means they look at the bird
outside their breakfast room
birders
tend to keep lists
okay
that's the quick definition birders keep
lists okay
and
have you been
seeing any nice birds here in copenhagen
since you arrived
i saw three different kinds of gull
okay that's it i was studying the gulls
on the flight up here from berlin so
that i would not be confused okay which
is more of a birder thing than a bird
watcher thing
okay
okay
well
we're going to talk about climate and
the biodiversity crisis this evening but
first we will talk a little bit about
your latest novel crossroads
and i will just give a very brief
summary to the people here who maybe
haven't read the book
the story takes place in a parish in a
christian community in the beginning of
the 1970s
to be precise most of the novel takes
place during one day
on the 23rd of december 1971.
the novel is about a family the father
ross is a priest he's married to marion
and they have four children clem the
oldest who has left for college becky
perry and johnson who live all live at
home
russ hildebrand the father of the family
comes from a mennonite background mary
and his wife is from a non-religious
household in northern california
initially quite well off from a family
with money
as a young woman she becomes christian
and remains to be a strong believer
throughout her life
it is a book about religion and about
family and why about religion and family
well
family because i've been accused of
being a family novelist and i
decided to have my revenge by finally
writing a family novel
to show what i mean by a family novel
which is
a book in which most of the scenes are
between family members and that also
follows a family over
multiple generations
rather than being just a convenient
organizing principle
which it has been in my previous five
books
religion
kind of
seemed like it was time to write about
religion uh
what do i mean by that um
the whole i so okay so stepping back
sorry um
try to introduce some energy here so i
initially thought of writing a book that
would follow a family for 50 years
and um and then i found myself
writing only the first part of that and
publishing it as a novel
with the thought that i might
die before i had to write the other two
novels and
um
which introduced a certain pressure on
this novel to really be a novel and not
just the first part of something anyway
um the idea came to me really all in one
piece and it had to do with
what i was thinking about five years ago
in terms of
the disappearance of the christianity
i'd grown up with
and its reappearance
uh in strikingly similar form
in the
beliefs
even the dogmas of certain
kinds of progressive activism
certainly
environmentalists climate in particular
had
just really striking parallels with the
protestantism i grew up with
but also
more generally the progressive program
which
whose principles kind of flow out of
what had been liberal christian thought
50 years ago
and which is also founded on
unprovable beliefs
and so i thought oh hey i'll finally
write a novel about religion i know a
thing or two about it
and i started with christianity because
that was still something
you could write a novel about in 1971
not so much anymore unless you want to
have a bunch of rabid trumpists who
want to control what women do with their
bodies and so forth
there was another question that i was
thinking about the religious environment
that you described would you find that
type of environment today in the united
states you think
it's a similar type of not really it was
it was widespread then people forget how
important the liberal church was in the
anti-war movement 50 years ago
how central beginning with martin luther
king it was in the civil rights movement
that kind of christian activism
has essentially disappeared it is still
an important part of the left the
democratic party in the united states
and that important part consists almost
entirely of african-american women
among white people
people just left the church
the same way they did in denmark the
same way they did across western europe
so yeah their little pockets like our
trainer in santa cruz
i have a trainer
otherwise i would not work hard at the
gym
and
our trainer is he's a gay guy
he's been out since he was like 15 but
he was part of this
little pocket of
out there
youth christianity in santa cruz there's
a specific cafe
where
where all the baristas are christian and
many of them are also gay um but that's
very rare it's like you can you find
that one little speck of it remaining
most of it is gone
okay should we maybe hear a little piece
from the novel uh i found a piece where
ross is having a conversation with the
young widow francis
and
the piece that thomas will read is from
page
404 and i just want to say before you
begin that
it's brilliantly translated by the
danish translator mick oh
and you can begin
again
night
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
did you did you pick out that passage
yes i did
i'm curious why
well uh i would actually want you to say
something about why what is taking place
and then i i will say something
afterwards
what is happening in the scene well the
the backdrop is that russ is trying very
hard to commit adultery
and he's he's gone to rather extreme
lengths and he's
he's chosen a woman who's very hard to
get
and every time he starts to lose
interest she interests him and every
time he
seems about to get there she backs away
um so and now this terrible thing has
happened because the whole thing they
had in common was they were together
going to the south side of chicago every
two weeks
to work in this poor black church and
she's saying i can't do it anymore
that's and he's like well as your pastor
i have to say
that's wrong you're a lovely person but
it's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm not gonna see her every two weeks
anymore this is the end so that's really
i mean as far as i'm concerned
um and by the way the entire notion that
this whole
story element is supposed to be
ridiculous it's it is
comical that russ is trying so hard to
be a bad person
and here she keeps saying no but you're
a good person it's like no no i'm not
that good i'm not that good
um so that's
to me that's the important thing and
then yes uh
you try to
within the larger ridiculous
quasi-love story you're telling you try
to
actually imagine conversations that have
some other things going on in them um
and i guess perhaps we could also
explain that some of the back story was
that she was her ver one of her first
times
she was screamed at almost assaulted by
the mother of this
handicapped little boy and she has taken
an interest in the boy
and basically
the minister down there has said
forget about it there's no helping it
and can you just say a little bit about
francis who is she
she's a terrible flirt
okay so
just a few words son just a few words
she's she's 15 years younger than russ
she's an attractive young widow her
husband was
killed in an accident
um exactly yeah and he and he really
adores her
he really does
and
[Music]
and he's obsessed with her he is kind of
obsessed with her um
so
i do occasionally need to draw on my own
real life
most of the book is invented but there
are these little tiny sources and i
realized i'd never
really told the story of the 10 months i
spent pursuing a woman who is somewhat
like francis
and in fact
the line in english is the i'm a crap
human being
that's from real life
and yeah yeah so well good answer there
you go well i mean i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna quote uh
a little passage from what we just heard
in english and this is gonna be
a threat i mean you will understand why
i i chose this piece okay
i can't accept that god creates a
situation so terrible there's not no
getting out of it
to me it's little
it's like there is a door and behind the
door is the inner city
and everywhere you turn there is a
situation so terrible that no one can
fix it
and i've reached the point where i just
can't open the door again i just want to
shut it
and forget what's behind it
this is what francis says
and now comes my question
do you think this is a reaction typical
of human nature
just wanted wanting to shut the door and
not open it again to see what's behind
it
absolutely and
you know it's kind of
what happened with the civil rights
movement
we did have progress in the 1960s
there was a body of legislation and it
really came to consciousness
that america has has to deal with the
legacy of slavery and then a century of
apartheid that followed that and people
got it
and there was a lot of political support
for it initially
and then i think a lot of white people
re just had the feeling
oh but this is so deep
and this is not going to be fixed easily
going to a march
passing this legislation it's actually
not going to fix it and i think that for
ordinary people
um
you just reach a point where i i don't
want to think about that anymore and
then nationally we had kind of 40 years
where people said okay we fixed that
we now have black university presidents
and look at all the black people going
to harvard
and so forth and
and look our schools are no longer
segregated and
it was just like okay i just i i thought
about it and i don't want to think about
it anymore i think that's a very common
reaction
and francis she's just been sort of
very disappointed
by the fact that she couldn't help this
she wanted to be the white savior yeah
she wants to be the life savior another
way to describe her would be the
horrible word karen
which is uh
which is really unfairly become the word
in america for the clueless white lady
um
and i have some of two of my best
friends are named karen and they are not
karen's so it's really like they're like
really you had to pick that name
um
but like there was this story i mean
we're just having fun here right so
there was two years ago i think it was
in central park which is one of the
great places in north america to bird or
to birdwatch
one of one of the
central
central park murders is this guy chris
cooper
who's african-american
and
the nicest person you will ever meet i
mean i i've birded with him in central
park everybody loves chris he's so
generous he's so he's just great
and bass and and yet
there was this woman who was letting her
dogs run in a no dog zone in the middle
of bird migration and disturbing all
sorts of birds and he very politely said
pointed to a sign and said you know your
dog should be on a
leash and she called the police
she was being threatened by a black man
[Music]
it didn't end well for her
she was nationally ridiculed called
karen
um i believe she lost her job
so she was she was totally shamed on
social media and paid a heavy price but
it was also terrible
because this is like
that was her first instinct even now in
2020 2021 whatever that was
there's
a black man who's unhappy with me he's
probably going to kill me
or at least rape me that's still the
mindset there in
for a lot of white people in america and
it's very hard to get past
yeah
it's not good
it's not good no it's not good but we
will leave that okay we'll move on yeah
we have even worse well even globally
worse problems to talk about
because this this thing about shutting
the door
brings me to the
this evening's main topic
which is climate catastrophe and
biodiversity
biodiversity crisis right
this conversation is part of the program
arctic imagination
initiated in
2017 with the question what do we do
when the arctic disappears
now we're not going to talk about the
arctic
but more about the biodiversity crisis
and maybe also a bit about birds
do you mind
talking about birds oh twist my arm i
guess i'll talk about birds if you
really force me well i mean not not too
long but i just want you to
tell us a little bit about
your
interest obsession uh passion about love
love just a little bit yeah
uh well the really short thing is i i
found my way to birds and i fell in love
with them and i
keep thinking i'll get tired of them and
no i never get tired of them
um
i just love birds and i really love all
kinds of birds but i particularly love
the little brown birds little brown
barks brown birds yeah
yeah that's not a species
although to the non-birder half the
birds in europe could be could have as a
species name little brown bird
because
all the colorful ones got eaten by
people and cats a long time ago and all
that's left is little brown bird uh
no it's really i think it it's um
it's as simple as that
how i came to love birds yeah what the
what went wrong with me psychologically
uh that that led to this when did it
begin it began about a little over 20
years ago in central park i i went there
one day in may
um i'd gotten involved with the
californian woman and
she loved animals so i was already
starting to pay attention a little bit
to animals
and
[Laughter]
we didn't have well actually we did have
pets when i was growing up but they were
teeny pets that could be kept in cages
and then they would die and then they
would and i bet i would not notice it
because i'd forgotten to feed them and
then i would discover decaying small
animals in cages so i was really turned
off by pets
um
oh and the poor turtle that i didn't put
the water in the tank for i was just
like awful so anyway i'd kind of trim my
back she opened my eyes and her sister
and brother-in-law are big birders
and they said you have binoculars yes
come to central park they'd come
especially to central park as people
from around the world do in may because
it is truly one of the best places in
the world
during bird migration in the middle of
new york city
and
they started showing me stuff and in
like three hours we saw 50 species of
bird
50. 55-0
minimum minimum 50 kinds of bird in the
middle of central park on a saturday in
may wow yeah
and it was like there's something here
that i hadn't been aware of
there is another world
and i've just had my first glimpse of it
and um and it went from there
yes soon i got better binoculars
and then i got a telescope and then i
got software for listing the birds i'd
seen and then suddenly i was going on
trips overseas to seabirds and it's just
gotten worse and then you became a
lister oh i did become a listener and
what is that
it's something you're very embarrassed
about well it's something you should be
embarrassed about
so um what is a lister a a lister is so
we we like to imagine
that it's all about the joy of nature
and the beauty of the birds and
how fascinating their behavior is
all true and yet
most birders will also at the end of the
day write down everything they saw
they keep a list
and
they'll also perhaps start keeping a
list of what they saw in another place
or in a given calendar year
or in a specific place in a specific
calendar year and so and so you get lots
of
lists and it's really kind of you feel
suddenly you feel like somebody who's
collecting like needs to get every
single beatles record ever pressed
which
which is uncool
i mean it's fascinating but the person
who's got to have that one pressing that
like
and they've
they've found it on the internet and it
costs 500 pounds
and
you know you don't want to be that guy i
don't want to be that guy
okay
so kind the kind construction is that
the list
makes it into a game it's it's of course
it's my love i i i don't have to keep a
list i can i can be happy looking at the
when i am happy looking out the window
whenever i see a bird i'm happy
but
there's another little game i can play
which is how many species have i seen
out that window
and
and i like games too
apes games i like games okay well that
brings me to the next question
maybe you're going to the apes i don't
know
in in 2020
you did a ted talk named save what you
love
and you initiated your speech with the
following quote
i'm here on the behalf of other species
end of quote
right
yeah
yeah it was actually tedx i i'm not
cool enough to do a real ted talk
tedx are these little satellite
ted weekends um
and there was one in santa cruz that
they got like 150 people to pony up
their money for
um
but apparently you can see it online too
so it's having a life of its own
what did you mean by that well
i knew what other people so it was
divided the day was divided or the
weekend was divided into four parts and
and this was the um i think it was
generally about climate or the state the
world was in and everyone was talking
about you know human problems and so i
just wanted to go out and
change the tone
and
i wrote my ted talk that morning
um and it's
and they kept saying don't you want to
practice it no i don't really want to
practice it
um
but no i noticed that you had a
different style than
you had the unprepared style
no not unprepared that was that was
thinking but you just were a little bit
more relaxed a little bit sort of i
don't know different well because it was
so you know was so
kind of heartbreaking up in the up in
the green room everyone had been told
memorize your speech it's important you
memorize your speech and they were
everyone was off in their own corner
that you could just see them trying to
memorize their whole ted talk like
what a bad way to go on stage
fearing you're going to forget your
lines so anyway
i just thought i thought yeah that's the
line to begin with i'm going to talk
i'll be the one person today who might
say a word about other species
the other species we
share the planet with and depend on and
come from and are one of
yeah that's where that came from
yeah
and
and what is what does it mean to be
speaking on behalf of other species
they can't speak for themselves
most of the losses are invisible
they take place we live we mostly live
in cities
and city-like places or we live in
europe which
is becoming
almost biologically sterile and if you
don't encounter the species you hardly
notice them missing you might notice oh
20 years ago we used to have to wash our
windshield when we drove in the country
now we don't have to wash our windshield
you might notice that you probably don't
why because there are no insects left
and
and so
in a really basic way if you care about
the natural world you have to start out
by saying hey you know what there is a
natural world and it is filled with
plant and animal species
because it's so easy to forget as we
live in a more and more virtual
and human constructed environment
well yeah that's very true
and you have been speaking about this
issue in
many different arenas you've been
writing about it and i think you have to
correct me if i'm wrong but wasn't it in
2017 that you wrote the essay
for the new yorker about climate change
called what if we stopped pretending and
then it was rewritten and republished in
19 is that correct no it was that was
written afresh that was written as a
speech um in 2019 and then i made it
into an essay no that was a different i
think there was a guardian essay in
2017. yeah okay which was different okay
yeah i took three shots at writing about
climate change i didn't
like set out to be a person who wrote
about climate change it was concern
about what's happening to the natural
world
concern that a whole conversation about
what's happening to the natural world
was being really really radically
sidelined because the only issue we
could talk about environmentally was
climate change
exactly yeah
and in in this essay
you say a lot of different things but
one thing you say is that the goal has
been clear for 30 years and despite
earnest efforts
we have made essentially no progress
toward reaching it
and a little further down in the same
passage you continue
there are two ways to think about this
you can keep on hoping that a
catastrophe is preventable and feel ever
more frustrated or enraged by the
world's
inaction or
you can accept that disaster is coming
and begin to rethink what it means to
have hope
i did write that
sorry i did write that you did right
then yes
and um
what kind of reactions did you receive
i'm sure some of the audience in here
will know but can you just
tell the people that will not know what
happened afterwards so a really
remarkable thing happened um
there was an absolute firestorm on
social media
that
it being social media lasted 72 hours
and then that was over
um
and then there was
but why were people so angry
and who
who um
it was the people whose business it was
to
keep saying
oh we have we still have 10 years to
turn things around and save the planet
and
um
i think even if i published that essay
today i would have encountered less
hostility i think that i think people
have become a little more realistic in
just three years
um
but at the time it was
like saying you like walking into a
church and saying
this is not the body and blood of christ
this is bread and grape juice
and you know just like the entire
congregation says what are you saying
it's like that it was that intensity
when someone comes along and challenges
the dogma
um
and
and i think precisely because it wasn't
written in an antagonistic spirit
unlike honestly some of my earlier
writings about climate change which had
been a little bit more antagonizing
because it was written in a measured
way
it was even more threatening it was and
and literally
i don't read the stuff myself but
i think it was the washington post's
climate journalist
the instruction in the tweet was don't
read this piece
like this is so this this is so
blasphemous
your soul is in peril if you take 10
minutes to read 2 000 words on this
subject because it's so terrible he is
such a terrible person and that was
basically the upshot was
we all knew franzen was a terrible
person and now we really know he was a
terrible person um so that was
that was social media
how did you feel about it
i was sorry that i
that i had friends who are not good
enough friends
to know that they shouldn't tell me what
people were saying
but you must have been curious no no you
were not no
no but here's the thing
the same so
the morning it came it landed on a
sunday morning
at and it was only it was online only
um and
uh
i actually
emailed all my friends to say you know i
have a piece coming out in the new
yorker i'm afraid no one's gonna see it
because it's online
and by six in the evening california
time i had like 150 emails in my public
email
inbox
crazy thing
for
were hostile for what four of the 150
responses were hostile
okay only four
everyone else was saying
hey thanks for saying that i've been
thinking something like that myself i
really appreciate your saying it and
that
slower response continues to i still
hear from people saying oh i just found
your way to that thank you for saying
that so
to me it was mostly instructive as
an instance of the disconnect between
twitter which is what gets reported on
and the way actual human beings respond
to an actual piece of writing
which is really different from the way
it happens on social media
and
yeah so it was sort of sad although did
not tell me anything i didn't already
know about twitter
but i read somewhere that you said that
you that they these sort of trolls or
whatever we should call them on social
media then in some ways they reach their
goal because you felt so embarrassed
afterwards oh yeah no just knowing it
was out there i did feel very ashamed
and why
did you feel that you did something
wrong
okay so something wrong
well
in that piece i don't think i did no
i did exactly what i wanted
my only worry was that no one would
notice
um and people did notice but um
so i remember
i was being taunted in ninth grade
english class
at that point i had
two or three friends
um
and one of them was a friend from
kindergarten
and he was a cool kid
unlike me i was the opposite of a cool
kid and there was this guy in
like
just
just to be cruel and 14 years old he was
he was taunting me saying
jonathan's favorite book is the
dictionary
in other words he's thought you know he
you couldn't get any less cool than me
honestly you couldn't get any less cool
than i was i was the uncoolest 14 year
old you ever met but
um
i turned and my friend ben was in the
same class my oldest friend
still a good friend
but not in ninth grade because i turned
to ben just like defend me against this
[ __ ]
and he sort of smirked at me and said
he's right john
and it was like this terrible betrayal
and i felt so ashamed like everyone in
class is like
i'm the i'm the weirdo different guy i
mean you just feel shame when you're in
that situation and and to know that
people are saying oh he's a terrible
person he's a terrible person
you know even if well in some ways i am
a terrible person but not in the ways
they're saying i'm a terrible person but
no but the thing is that i mean i i
guess you were not surprised that the
right winged or the ignorant people were
angry at you but
people from the left wing the
environmentalists the climate
activists and so forth they were angry
at you as well and why
the right wing was not angry at me the
right way no they didn't care
it was the left wing yeah yeah no
exactly well because
and can you say something about what
what did you say you stated something
about
climate and biodiversity crisis and what
did you say
was what was it that made them so angry
um
well let me think back what was it that
made them so angry um
i like to think i just said what was
true which is all these
all these things about oh we'll keep
global bean temperature from rising more
than 1.5 degrees celsius
this century
it's nonsense have you talked to a
climate scientist who's not an activist
and asked what they think
the likely temperature rise in this
century is going to be it's not 1.5
degrees
that's for sure
so simply to say that out loud and to
say
and you know what it's probably worse
than we think because every time we've
predicted something in the last 30 years
it turns out to be worse than what was
what was modeled
the arctic since we are here sort of in
the rubric of the arctic
um
though the arctic is warming up so much
faster than anyone would have guessed
ten years ago except for the people who
kept saying oh you know there are some
feedback loops here you got better be
careful of the
the feedback loops when the permafrost
melts and the methane goes up and when
the
the ice stops reflecting the sun you
know a few people were saying that but
not many so it just it was like
come on guys
really 1.5 degrees celsius as your goal
maybe two maximum worst case come on
that's what they were mad about because
if
it is too late to stop runaway
climate change
then it changes
then then
well for one thing entire careers are
premised on the fact that it's not too
late so you have a career stake you've
you've been an activist for 30 years
you're getting more and more frustrated
because
co2 emissions basically until we had the
pandemic
with a little blip and maybe 2008 2009
because of the global recession they've
just gone steadily up that whole time
you're already frustrated as hell and
now someone is
coming along and saying you know what i
don't really see it i don't see that
that curve going like that
anytime soon not with china and india
and the us and brazil
and frankly the european union doing
what they're doing
people you get mad you have you have a
career stake you have your whole life
has been dedicated to
this salvational principle it really and
that's where the religious thing comes
in it's like you are actually attacking
someone's religion
if we feel guilty enough and because we
feel guilty we change our lives we might
be saved and if you challenge that idea
if you say well salvation hmm
it's threatening and people get angry
when they're threatened
so
is that what you did that you i mean you
you didn't ask people not to reduce
emissions and stops oh i did oh yeah i
didn't say that you just said that well
i mean we're far beyond i mean
the 1.5 and maybe we should
spend our energy on something else and
what was what was that
some of our energy at the time when i
first started writing about it i said
hey can we also maybe try to take care
of the natural world
we're we're in the midst of a mass
extinction event
that has nothing to do
with climate change climate change will
make it all very much worse and will
begin
to
really sink its teeth in in the coming
decades
but the oceans aren't going dead because
of climate change the oceans are going
dead because we're fishing them to death
that's you know stuff like that like
maybe maybe
and then but you read about
the crisis of the ocean you read on the
front page of the newspaper the crisis
the ocean they always say climate change
is is wreaking havoc on the oceans it's
like
excuse me how
like that's what you have to say first
you have to because that's the religion
the religion means you have to bow down
before the all-important climate change
oh and then we mentioned maybe
overfishing
things like that it's
i've gotten carried away but no i was i
was by no means saying stop trying to
reduce our carbon emissions but if i can
just rant a little bit more here since
we are talking about the arctic now
let's talk about california
in greater new york there is enough roof
space
to power
metropolitan new york with solar energy
there are a lot of big flat buildings on
long island and there are a whole lot of
roofs
and that's a place that gets a lot of
rain it's cloudy the sun is low in the
winter go to southern california
there's more than enough sun in
california throughout the state to
completely power the state
how are we going about harnessing the
sun
what would make sense would be to put
solar panels on all the buildings the
buildings are already there like why go
wreck
thousands of square miles when we have
already wrecked
thousands of square miles of city
it would make sense right now in the
state of california there is a huge
effort supported by major environmental
groups
to make it difficult
economically almost impossible to put
solar panels on your own roof
why
because large-scale solar installations
are better
why are they better
because the so the electricity company
doesn't own what's on your roof they're
not making any profit when they when
they're in fact having to pay you
sometimes for the solar energy you're
generating
but they will own the big solar array so
in america if you want to try to get
solar power in place you have to start
with utilities labor unions also labor
unions love the idea of massive
like pave over the mojave desert why
because those are all union jobs on you
know maybe they should be union jobs
putting it on on the roof of house but
right now it's not so you have this like
there's a right way to do it in a wrong
way to do it and
and why are we choosing the wrong way
why are we just looking at the natural
world as this expendable thing that we
can pave over without considering maybe
there's some benefit to keeping some
open spaces
um
well for the birds yes okay right i i
freely admit i love birds and i have a
selfish interest in not seeing the world
go birdless but
but this is what like can't that be part
of this conversation why do we have to
just immediately jump to the easiest
politically most expedient
um
dumb solution that doesn't take the
natural world into account that's all
i'm saying really
why is everything
[Music]
in the ted talk you say that we have
lost sight of the beauty of the world
and the beauty of nature and you say
that now in our time it has become clear
that we lost the battle against climate
change that we just talked about and
therefore we should spend our resources
on resilience you say
what do you mean by that what kind of
resilience do you mean all kinds
can you just
say a little bit more from that
so well i obviously
we actually depend on natural ecosystems
so it kind of makes sense to
put some work and some resources into
making
the nat
what remains of the natural world more
resilient for example the oceans
forests
small aside great story the other day
and
about how we are cutting down old growth
forests in central europe in order to
make wood chips to make renewable energy
like
maybe don't do that
[Laughter]
but
but more broadly
my contention which is already
i think bearing itself out in real time
my contention is that
if you have shock after shock drought
fire
water shortages or conversely flooding
um catastrophic storms
uh wind events
um if you have these it's just shock
after shock to every system
and that includes political systems
and it has been long been a contention
of mine that the some of the rise in
populist nationalism
which i consider deplorable um both at
home and also in various european
countries
where it's where it's really becoming a
force
um
that's a that's i think that
that grows out of in part
a rational recognition
that things are going to get very very
unstable and what do you do when things
get really unstable you you protect your
own
you become kind of tribal about it
um and and i think actually
even though it's seldom spoken of
underlying a lot of the
question of immigration in europe i
think there is a recognition that oh
this is just the beginning
and
and and
so
you need to actually pay attention to
your political system
because you as societies become stressed
certain things become important like
fair elections and
in the u.s gun control and
frankly law and order it is
we
when you have shock after shock and that
is what
catastrophe looks like it's not like a
sheet of fire sweeping the planet that's
not the future we're looking at we're
just looking at oh for god's sake no
more shocks and here comes another shock
you
you
every structure that supports a humane
and just society becomes something that
actually needs care you need to think
about how to strengthen those systems
so really it's the entire gamut from the
natural world to um
for my sake liberal democracy
and we need to be
more nice to each other but we also do
need to be nicer to each other we have
to become that's part of the resilience
yeah i think so anything that makes that
encourages people to be kinder i think
is always a good thing
and if you'd like to put that on a
greeting card we can work out a
trademark agreement
well i would like to return to
crossroads not leaving the subject
though
but it would be nice if thomas levine
would read a passage late in the book
a scene that is taking place on the
navajo reservation in arizona do you
want to follow or
i kind of know it but sure yeah it's up
to you
yeah
say clyde
foreign
still
[Applause]
so jonathan what is happening in this
passage
what happened before what what kind of
well well
most of the book happened before
so
[Music]
it's a long story but russ found himself
spending a lot of time with the navajos
in the 1940s and uh he has
in particular one
friend a person he considers a friend
among the navajos that's keith deroshi
and
now he's back with a busload of
suburban kids there for a 10-day work
camp
and uh
and he's been warned yet don't go up
there
keith said don't go up there um
and then indeed they get threatened um
by clyde and clyde's friends and then
clyde breaks in steals some guitars from
the young white kids and russ has gone
up to get the guitars back basically
and he's taken francis with him he's
still pursuing
francis it's like i don't know however
100 pages later she's still holding out
it's quite pathetic
yeah
um i'm glad you're laughing because you
should be
yeah oh uh what else no no just i mean i
chose this passage because of the
subject that we're talking about
right um
interestingly peabody cole um when i
grew up at st louis when we go downtown
to the frightening
black inner city across the river across
the mississippi river there was the
biggest thing you saw was peabody coal
which had a huge coal processing plant
that was the coal they were mining in
illinois but that was also the same
company that
had a huge coal mine in the middle of
navajo country what was then the
reservation is now the navajo nation
um and
uh
and that coal
those that and then they built a power
plant next to it
and it's exactly as clyde says that that
power all went to las vegas
some of our power in california i mean
we and we now have solar so we don't
rely on it but um you know i've used
power from the navajo plant in
california
so
it's a real life thing and that that
thing about the sierra club that's real
life too
um
and someone like ross who wants to do
the right thing and who's
very aware of racism and
no he's right that's right how does he
react to this he's felt good about his
cultural sensitivity he was ahead of his
time in terms of his sensitivity
um toward other cultures his respect for
other cultures he was way ahead of his
time that's that's been his his thing in
a way and that's one of the really
genuinely admirable things about him is
that he is very sensitive
and now someone is coming along and
saying
yeah you've been sentimentalizing
exactly something here
um and it's also 19 keep in mind this is
this is april 1972 that was precisely
the moment when the american indian
movement
was
in force and
there was this younger generation
of native americans
on the res and also off who were just
saying you know to hell with that you
you were so proud dad of what you got
from the white people
you didn't get anything so that it's
just
it's a little bit of american history
really that's what's going on here
yeah and it takes place in the beginning
of the 1970s and if you should compare
with today
the navajo reservation today or the
environment the navajo reservation today
is still a very poor place um and
it has been
uh
per capita
if not the hardest hit certainly one of
the hardest hit places in america by
covid in terms of both infection rate
and particularly deaths
it just got really hammered
and
there is
it's not as visible as black lives
matter it's not as visible as the
discourse on systemic racism but i think
there's a similar thing happening with
revisiting what we thought was
settled law in the 60s and 70s and
saying hey you know what
and i in fact one of my i have a friend
who actually grew up not
identifying as native american um
but he now does
which is not an opportunistic thing it
was sort of like yeah i guess i better
admit
that i'm
native american he didn't grow up in a
reservation he grew up with a white
family actually
he is
he is now he's working as a screenwriter
and there is very very deliberately in
hollywood
uh an interest in getting native
americans to write about native
americans in hollywood because there's
this like hundred year history of white
people not only writing
the native american experience but also
acting it
and so they're you know there's stuff
it's it's it's it's very much
happening right now actually in and in
very in very positive ways and so
like yep
yeah
not everything in america is bad there
is there's some genuine progress being
made
that's nice to hear
i would like you to read a passage from
an essay that you have written the essay
in
dark times
i think it's from 2017 isn't that right
yes
it's just a very short passage beginning
on
21 and then
i'm actually
not as bad a person as what people say
on twitter but i'm not a great person i
wrote this most of this essay as a
speech
to be delivered in um
at a prize thing in switzerland and uh
and then i found out that that one of
the uh requirements was that it'd be
published for free in um
in swiss and german newspapers
and i'm one of those old-fashioned
writers who said
you know what
writers should be paid
was also published in danish newspaper
why
because
i said
pay me something
pay me one euro
and they were like no no no no no
and i said well then [ __ ] it i'm going
to give a different speech
um and so and this got published as an
essay in the guardian
um
so
and yeah just like being fully honest
about
although there was a principle at stake
which is that writers should be paid for
their
were for work that is printed i at the
time i was like
don't you understand there's a principle
at stake but i was being kind of an
[ __ ] too and the speech i gave was
terrible and
i should have given this one
anyway
here's what you've selected for me to
read
not one of the funny bits i noticed
but that's okay
i really did want to change the climate
but okay so that takes some explanation
i wanted to make it hotter
so i'd gotten very upset when people
were telling me all the nasty things
people were saying about me and i'd gone
to my editor at the new yorker magazine
and
he'd said yeah
ignore it it's just weather
you're trying to you're not trying to
change the weather you're trying to
change the climate which meant the
intellectual climate
so
that is what i'm referring to here i
really did want to change the climate
i sort of pretended no i was just
writing this
for the for a person who might want to
hear it no actually i really did want to
try to contribute to the conversation i
really did want to change the climate
i still do
well maybe not so much now um i share
with the very people my essay criticized
the recognition that global warming is
the issue of our time perhaps the
biggest issue in all of human history
every one of us is now in the position
of the indigenous americans
when the europeans arrived with guns and
smallpox
our world is poised to change vastly
unpredictably
and mostly for the worse
i don't have any hope that we can stop
the change from coming my only hope is
that we can accept the reality in time
to prepare for it humanely
and my only faith is that facing it
honestly however painful this may be is
better than denying it
[Music]
christina why did you choose that
passage
i chose it because i wanted you to tell
us how how do you perceive it today i
mean this was in 9 c now in 22 and would
you write the same would you phrase it
the same way or would you phrase it
differently today
so in fact that's the end of an essay
about essays
and
and
[Music]
i was finding fault
actually with an earlier essay
in which i'd really been rather hostile
to certain environmental groups
and i was having regrets about that
realizing
cliche you catch more flies with honey
than with vinegar
that that in fact
instead of
denouncing people who are lying and who
don't understand instead of doing that
it's better to say you know
i have some questions i'm really
confused and i actually i'm frightened
to to to to kind of lead with one's
humanity rather than stand back in this
really stern position
like many activists still do
you might actually have a have more
effect
with a softer tone that's really what
that essay was about it was about the
process of revision
and the process of revision
for a writer is
actually trying to get to a better place
as a person
um
and you the great thing about writing is
you get to do it over you get to do it
over before it's first published and
then you get to do it over again when
you try to write about the same subject
again
you're you're actually trying to make
some progress
um
and and it is a reciprocal relation
between the writer and what is written
it's not magic i can't make myself a
perfect person
simply by writing about how i'd like to
be a perfect person but it does have a
there is a back and forth
that's really what i was
that's what i was saying might be the
essence of the essay
which is itself
a threatened life form people don't
write essays so much
anymore
uh
pure essays
so that was a literary this was it was
in fact a literary essay
using
a climate essay as an example of an
essay as a firefighter
well yeah that was
um that was one of the metaphors i came
to was a very good one
yeah the
the essayist job i think i can sort of
quote myself
again greeting card material if you'd
like to speak to me afterwards
i could just say the writer's job
when everyone else is like a firefighter
when everyone else is fleeing the flames
you're supposed to run right into them i
was specifically talking about the
flames of shame
we
especially in our social media world we
go to elaborate lengths to avoid shame
but an essay has got a gun gotta run the
risk of shame you've got to go toward
precisely the things that are making you
uncomfortable and get into them that's
your job like the firefighter's job
do you think that that the consciousness
in the states or maybe in europe as well
has changed since you wrote that essay
for the better
maybe for the worse
well many things have gotten worse we
have
this war
um it's weird actually i've been of
course
well informed about the war but it was
weird landing in germany um on thursday
it's like oh well now i'm on a continent
where there's an actual war going on
um
so yeah a lot of terrible things
happening
kind of not the worst
year for
america
sort of maybe in its own
weak way doing a little bit about the
climate situation
possibly setting a better example
we did get some legislation last month
it's called the reduce inflation bill or
whatever it's a
crazy thing like that they can't even
they don't even dare call it climate
that's like it's the inflation reduction
act
which makes no sense i mean like lots of
extra government spending yeah that'll
really lick inflation um anyway uh
but yeah i actually
i have
i have noticed that the rhetoric has
changed a little bit yes people still
talking about
well we'll all get electric cars and
save the planet
just like fingernails on chalkboard your
electric car will not save the planet
sorry
do the math
talk to a scientist sorry
is it bad to have an electric car no
it's a very good thing
it's also a kind of virtue signaling
it's also part of the whole
religion of climate but it is
in fact better to
not pollute with your car than to
pollute with your car no question not
making fun of electric cars just the
phrase saved the planet that has become
a little less common in just three years
and
you s
much less frequently in the paper i read
which is the new york times
see the phrase
keep global mean temperatures from
rising more than a degree and i have you
don't see that so much anymore and
you're much more likely
to see the phrase
to avoid the worst outcomes
that has become the phrase of choice
that's progress
right
that's like
sometime
in the last three years things have
tipped a little bit and actually fewer
people are pretending to the same degree
they were
just three years ago
you still hear we still have 10 years
it's like but i think i think the people
who are saying that will soon be laughed
out of the room um but yeah i think so i
do i do feel the climate has changed i
don't take any credit for that
um i just got there early so that i
could be extra specially reviled for
having spoken up first
but
and i wasn't even the first i mean
there's jem bendel i hadn't even read
jim bendel um and and his
you know this thing about the grief uh
deep adaptation adapting to the
knowledge that we've basically wrecked
the planet um there was there was a but
there was a large body of writing along
these lines that i've subsequently
become aware of so and i do think i
think the whole thing has changed a
little bit um for the better
the better
yeah i just the the dishonesty level has
gone down a bit still high but it's gone
down a bit and is it your
do you do you see people
changing lifestyles i mean
like having wild gardens or i mean do
you see
any change in the states
around you
um
i mean the electric car of course but do
you see other changes
yeah uh
well
i
not not in a world-changing way no i
don't um
we do you know more and more people do
have solar electric on their house when
it's california
and more and more people drive
non-carbon burning cars
and i think
i live in a very
privileged community in that it's super
super liberal and we've been talking for
decades about locally grown food
and organically grown food
um
maybe
maybe
a little
maybe a few more people have come around
to that not so much
though okay
well we actually don't have very much
time left okay we have nine minutes to
be precise um and i would just like to
end this very nice conversation
with crossroads again
because as i understand
it's the first novel out of three
under a common title
a key to all mythologies looks like
we're going to be ending this evening
about eight minutes early if that's
going to be the question
yes go on go on sorry christina go on
you were saying well no but we were just
talking about i mean we're talking about
your novel and the christian community
in the novel in the 70s and we're
talking how you were talking about the
environmental movement being in some way
a religious uh
in some ways anyway and really just move
um
and and and now you are actually going
to write two more books
diving into
something mythological and i was just
curious to to hear what you were going
to explore
and what is mythology today
this is this is maybe the time to
mention
as many of you know that the key to all
mythologies is a title from literature
and it refers to a grand project that
was never completed
because its would-be author
died
at a sadly young age
although a much greater age than his
very young wife dorothea
you have to take off your glasses
so i'm not really a very conceptual
writer in fact i'm not a conceptual
writer at all um
i am a very nuts and bolts writer i need
a story and i need some characters and
the characters are defined by their
stories and it's actually harder than
you might think to come up with a good
story that is a good character um takes
me years and years to come up with just
a few characters
um and once i'm once i have those
characters i'm focused on the mechanics
of telling a good story the important
thing is you want to read the next
sentence and once you read that one you
want to read the sentence after that
that's what i'm focused on as a writer
and yes i start out with the grand idea
and if i hadn't had a grand idea i might
not have made a lot of the decisions i
made here i might not have made one of
the main characters a minister
and i might not have set the thing in a
church
partly
but it's once i'm writing i forget about
it
so
uh it could be that we will take up some
other versions of
more recent mythologies
but it's not going to help me get the
books written that's for sure
it's the sort of thing you remember
at a moment
when
you're stuck for an idea for the next
paragraph oh yeah there was that big
concept i was working i could drop that
in for i can that'll help me
think of something to put in that
paragraph that's really the level i'm
not trying to demonstrate anything
because
i can summarize that concept of evolving
mythologies
in about two sentences on stage and why
would you read an entire book in order
to get a idea that i can summarize in
two sentences that's the problem with
concepts and novels in my opinion
okay
[Applause]
maybe this is a very depressing question
i don't know but
do you find it difficult to write in in
a in a time of
of sort of
the end of the worlds type of feeling do
you find it difficult to to dive into
fiction i know that you do essays and
many of them but do you find it harder
now than you did before
well because i'm older and i've used up
most of my good material of course it
gets harder
and also i feel i've established a
certain standard and i that i i feel my
work needs to live up to
if i'd established a lower standard
everything would be easier now
you don't have to dig very deep in that
statement to find a lot of authorial
self-regard
but we'll skate past that
[Laughter]
no
in fact crossroads is a product of the
trump administration
and what could be better than going into
a world of my own making for six hours a
day seven days a week
and
that is 42 hours a week fewer i was not
spending in the world in which donald
trump was president it was like
not hard at all
but beyond that
you know we all have these very finite
lives ahead of us and
um
and it's important to have your little
projects
like
the color of that room has bothered me
for 15 years
it's a pain to repaint it but this
summer i'm going to repaint it
um
like that's something to look forward to
we won't hate the color of that room
anymore um
or
and
and i enjoy being in a novel so why
wouldn't i
want to use some of my remaining time to
do something i enjoy doing and and i
actually think that it becomes more
important
to do the things we care about and to to
do things that ideally are welcome to or
maybe even help other people
um in in that limited time so
no i i it's
it's this we're living in this weird
moment the world i don't think is going
to end although the nuclear weapons are
still out there
i don't think the world is going to end
it's not going to like the sun's not
going to explode
nevertheless
things are going to be really
almost unrecognizably different a
century from now or maybe much sooner
than that and
it's like it's like our each of us
has our own individual death really writ
large
and ideally the fact that you are mortal
that nothing is going to last should
make you
invest more in your
your daily life and in the relationships
that matter and in the causes that
matter
um
so to my mind the impending catastrophes
are really no different than the the
impending death that we all face
okay
thank you
so on that note do you do you have one
last thing you would like to say before
ending the conversation
to this
beautiful audience
well i want to thank
black diamond for having me does black
diamond call to mind a bob dylan song to
anyone else um
um and
and does anyone else feel as i did that
black diamond bay uh is
is based on his reading of the conrad
novel uh
victory
which is about
black diamond bay in fact the story that
is told in ballot form in black diamond
bay the dylan song is kind of the story
of
victory by joseph conrad um
and i'm just going to riff because i'm
so damn tired um i'm going to say that i
i remember loving victory the first two
times i read it and i went back and read
it a third time recently because i
thought i need to go back and reread
some conrad
and i had been
irritated with the kind of revisionist
critiques of conrad he was so far ahead
of
his contemporaries in terms of his
critique of colonialism it just seemed
kind of grotesque that he was now
accused of being an apologist for
colonialism
and i went back and i thought ooh
he's kind of bad in his representations
of
um
the non-white characters and he's
really really
sentimental and weak when it comes to
his depictions of women and the words he
uses so i that was sort of a
disappointment that's all coming off
black diamond bait which is going to
circle me back to thanking lisa for
setting up this wonderful series i'm
honored to be a part of it i am so
grateful to thomas for sitting on that
stools for so long as an actor and only
getting to talk for five minutes you
were great
and christina you had the hardest job so
thank you so much you're very welcome
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
i just want to say
before leaving the room i just want to
say that in the bookstore you can get a
signature after what's right now
actually
thank you very much
thank you
you